[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys so welt
heute gibt es wieder ein nachgemacht
video und in meinem letzten video oder
in einem meiner letzten videos in allem
habe ich gefragt was ich denn als
nächstes nach machen und viele von euch
haben geschrieben von ikea diese kleinen
strolchen und die haben wir jetzt hier
gefunden
ich muss sagen ich habe die noch nie
probiert also tatsächlich noch nie
und zwar gibt es die einmal als vanille
und als zitronen und die heißen hier
steht däfler natürlich muss jetzt erst
mal gucken wie man es ausspricht denn
köttbullar wie viele sagen heißt auch
nicht apple sondern köttbullar basta das
sind wir lernen von euch und jetzt habe
ich das hier mal gegoogelt ich habe es
noch nicht angehört 8 das steht sogar
aussprache von pen sehen wie nutzer
männlich aus schweden
heute gibt sie flach und zwar einmal
vanilla häfler und einmal 10
ich muss jetzt aber erst mal wissen wie
es schmeckt ich habe nur eine packung
deswegen schneiden ist also auch und
dann aber ich schätze mal es ist einfach
und hefeteig
wir können uns besser lesen was drin ist
wenn man die strecke ja hefegebäck
welchen mit cremes füllung mit
vanillegeschmack mehl zucker oder stärke
und so weiter aha natürlich ist man in
aroma
[Musik]
übrigens wenn irgendwo drauf steht
natürliches aroma
dann kann das als es muss nur
natürlichen ursprungs sein das heißt
kann auch sein dass zum beispiel
holzspäne verwendet werden und das auch
natürlich nur sprung da steht einfach
drauf natürliches aroma hierbei etwa
joghurt zum beispiel okay das ist jetzt
warte ich mach mal so auf
cremig sieht es nicht aus aber es riecht
gut gemeistert werden müssen
die schmecken trocken aber ist okay für
sonst hätt' ich produkt also bitte kauft
sie einfach nicht bitte hier
jetzt sind wir stehen bevor man sowas
ist ganz ähnlich geht lieber zum bäcker
vor ort unterstützt eure becker vor ort
also bevor ich mir so sind schnecken und
vanille schnecken aus der tüte kauft
[Musik]
kauft die auch nicht ich mache zum
rezept für euch und wir machen die jetzt
selber nach und zwar so dass wir besser
ok und vielleicht machen wir einmal den
normalen noch einmal in wega
ich war schon mal die zutaten ich habe
ich jetzt mal die zutaten für den
hefeteig gerichtet ich mache jetzt wie
gesagt einmal eine normale version und
eine vegane version im prinzip
unterscheiden die sich nicht viel
also ich hab hier einfach ein halben
würfel hefe jeweils etwas zucker und
wasser 250 gramm mehl etwas milch hier
habe ich an hafermehl ich stattdessen
ein eigelb habe ich hier und hier
einfach einen esslöffel apfelmus
selbstgemacht salz und butter eier
butter vertauscht hier ist die normale
butter und hieß die veganer butter also
das sind eigentlich die standard zutaten
das heißt ich bereite zweimal einen
hefeteig so hole mir ganz kurz mehr
kirchen maschine und er gibt jetzt
einfach die hefe den zucker und das
wasser in die rührschüssel ihr könnt den
teig auch mit der hand verkneten
und jetzt gibt dir einfach die
restlichen zutaten dazu die milch habe
ich ein bisschen erwärmt salz und butter
wirklich immer schön am ende dazu geben
damit die hefe schön aufgehen kann also
nicht direkt auf die hefe geben sondern
er dann auch die butter und jetzt den
teig einfach für mindestens fünf bis
zehn minuten schön weich kneten
[Musik]
hier ist der teig und das ist ein
richtig schöner weichert eick der aber
auch nicht geht also doch ein bisschen
klebt dann nimmt wirklich ganz ganz
wenig mehl nur denn er soll wirklich
nicht so fest sein sondern eher schön
weil ich vor mir jetzt zu einer kur war
nicht einfach immer super schön finde
perfekt und wie gesagt könnte jetzt
beide teile einfach abdecken und etwa
eine stunde aufgehen lassen oder im
backofen im dampf backofen bei der stufe
mit dampf unterstützung da braucht es
nur etwa 30 minuten
[Musik]
und dem backofen bei der stufe habt ihr
auch den vorteil dass der tag nicht
austrocknet an der oberfläche
[Musik]
während der teig jetzt noch aufgeht kann
ich schon mal die vanille füllung zu
bereiten
die mache ich jetzt für den normal
hefeteig also für den nicht veganen ich
nehme jetzt dafür 200 gramm schmandt ihr
könnt aber auch quark nehmen oder kein
trash oder ein anderes milchprodukt was
so ein bisschen fester ist als mit 1 140
gramm zucker 25 gramm stärke und etwas
vanille extrakt und dafür verrät jetzt
einfach alle zutaten
[Musik]
für später einfach alles verrühren
bevor das ganze rezept in einem
experiment endet denn die füllung ist
leider immer noch zu flüssig werde ich
sie jetzt doch erwärmung
ich wollte eigentlich ein pudding machen
ohne kochen und jetzt muss ich doch
erwärmen
denn wenn ich diese masse so auf den
teig gleich streichen dann läuft alles
aus also hier kurz die spaltmaße
erwärmen hätte ja auch mitnehmen können
egal
das gehört dann als kriminell wird jetzt
einfach kurzes während disco während des
kochens immer rühren und einfach so
lange bis die masse eindeckt also sie
muss nicht unbedingt auf kochen liegt
auch vorher schon ein bisschen ein
und dann reicht ist es eine schöne
streichfähige masse so dass jetzt
abkühlung
jetzt bereite ich erst einmal die
jeweilige schnecken zu die wanne lag
griff ich musste kurz und manuela
kessler gefragt in schieflage
es heißt ja sagen das ist schön weil ich
und jetzt schön ausrollen am besten zu
einem langen strang
die luft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe jetzt den teig 60 x 20 cm groß
ausgerollt das war natürlich schlauer
gewesen dass so auszurollen
denn ich muss gleich auf rollen aber ich
hab's gemacht
da kommt jetzt die füllung rein jetzt
schön verteilen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also von der breite her würde ich schon
vier zentimeter machen 4 cm
[Musik]
und hier oben drauf kommt jetzt eine
mischung aus eigelb etwas milch und
puderzucker puderzucker einfach damit
das ganze am schönen glanz bekommt und
karamellisierten brauchen wird
[Musik]
jetzt kommen die hier direkt in den
backofen
ich habe dir jetzt grade angestellt als
ihr könnt ihr noch im kalten backofen
schieben und dann den ofen an machen
hier können sie auch vorher noch
aufgehen lassen aber die sind nicht so
schön klein
die müssen eigentlich gar nicht lange
aufgehen und jetzt kurz backen und in
der zwischenzeit machen wir schon mal
die veganen
[Musik]
hier ist der weg gartenteich
unterstreicht jetzt jemand ist sich
schmecken draus die zimt give love a
überhaupt die packung als vegane weiche
butter oder halb weiche warum ich sehe
schon die kommentare jetzt 13 durch
[Applaus]
und dann vermisse ich jetzt sind um
zucker das darauf streuen
[Musik]
und jetzt auch hier wieder aufrollen
wenn ich genug mehr in trotz
[Musik]
mit ziel wieder schön auf die naht
drauflegen und dann wieder zurecht
schneiden
[Musik]
da jetzt hier bei den veganer natürlich
kein ei benutzen kann nämlich jetzt
einfach hafermehl und etwas zucker
verrührt das ganze und bestreicht die so
und gibt die dann auch in den kalten
backofen schallt den ofen an und danach
wenn sie gebacken sind werden wir sie
ihre kosten
[Musik]
also rein mit euch in den kalten
backofen backofen auf 180 grad stellen
und am backen bis sie schön goldbraun
sind und die aufheizzeit des backofens
nutzen die kleinen zimtschnecken als
aufgeht seite und dann gehen sie steht
auch vom bakken gleichzeitig sehr schön
guckt euch thema wetter an und ich habe
jetzt noch einen mega guten tipp für
euch und zwar habe ich sie gerade drei
minuten vor ende der backzeit noch mal
mit der einmischung gestrichen und guck
mal wieder schön glänzen
richtig gut jetzt nämlich sehr aus und
lasst sie kurz abkühlen
[Musik]
jetzt schon mal die erste variante die
vanille gfk
die gucken jetzt alles schön kann ich
nicht sagen was was ist noch kein
englisch
das ist eigentlich habe ich sarah
gemeinte provinz besucht dem auftritt wo
ich der typ im rosa hemmers erwartet
gerade noch auf die vegane als das
profil das jetzt mal also manchmal so
weil das schließt uns ist es nicht sagen
so nicht merkt was selbst gemacht ich
über seile hergestellt ist das ist
original das ist york city genau aber
ich probier's mal ehrlich wo will ich
mal jetzt also doch warum jetzt diese
auto aber schon richtig blöd sein warum
die autowelt jetzt auf seinem balkon ein
doch kaum fassen dass ich meine brötchen
anzupassen
die kompakte pandemie man merkt man
schmeckt ich merke industrie also ich da
unterschiedlich von den vier zutaten
jetzt darin unterschied ja was hat man
weniger oder mehr benutzt ich habe bei
mir bisschen mehr zucker rein machen
können ein bisschen mehr zucker in die
füllung schreibe ich euch ins rezept
aber ich habe jetzt keine 471 900 oder
elias und wunder vergessen mit 8607 202
e 282 101 160 a und e 330 watt aus weil
ich war deswegen haben wir auch
einbringen so marc die einkaufsliste
sack kaufen mit dem 604 e sie nur aber
man muss dazu sagen um jetzt mal das
produkt auch in schutz zu nehmen
ich will selbst nicht hätten oder so
kaufen müsste das trotzdem nicht aber
man muss ja auch so ein produkt haltbar
machen damit eben in seiner tüte
verkaufsfertig nicht eben nur einen tag
haltbar ist sondern wirklich ein paar
wochen remo norwegen muss man halt sagen
dass man etwas dazugeben
und es ist recycling papier bis nächsten
monat
wir zeigen euch mal den tipp dass
passive sicherheit gibt dann kann er
sich durchboxt
also ich hier nochmal zum vergleich
murat die sind vegan aber heißt wir
machen schon über etwas sagen muss aber
mehr kontrolle in die veganen am besten
schmecken
und weil mir zugehört und mehr butter
drin ist ja das ist einzige was mich bei
denen stadt ist dass der glanz fehlt
also der glanz auf der oberfläche fehlt
aber mein gott dann fällt er hat also
ich bin auch vegan vegan ist guter dinge
das beste also ich find ja auch am
besten macht gut macht's besser
das geben wir gerne macht selber und
schreibt gerne was ich als nächstes den
schongauer sie begann sie schmeckt mir
früher wenn man die sind aber auch union
zu wenig ca
michael
[Musik]